youtube is removing the dislike account
on all videos across this platform
that's right
i'm back again
poppy gloria with the news with the news
yeah
[Music]
they announced this yesterday evening
and at first i was like
who cares
i don't
but then i thought about it
and yeah i care i care now let me
explain why big deal so they announced
this back in march where they said they
were doing a small experiment this is
tiny experiment it's so small you can't
see it
nothing it's small and nothing's gonna
happen trust me bro they were also
saying are you removing the dislikes but
no
we are not removing the dislike button
fast forward to today youtube is
removing just like this
i get that they're not removing the
button apparently the button's still
gonna be there
but it's not gonna do anything
you won't see the dislikes on the video
it's great it's like when you give a
your little brother that controller and
it's not plugged in and they think
they're playing but really they're not
that's the equivalent of the button so
youtube made a post about this which i
appreciate i don't think they normally
would uh put this much time and effort
into communicating with the audience i
appreciate that i'm trying to give
good uh one good one common saying from
user one two three three four eight
continues this is good you should have
implemented this long time ago and then
there's no point in removing this
encounter if creators cannot handle
criticism he she should not present
anything to society at all
all right we got some different opinions
we got some discussion which doesn't
matter ultimately because they're
removing it but anyway so youtube
announcing today or yesterday that what
they learned from this tiny experiment
is that
if people couldn't see
the dislike number through their data
and extensive research
market research statistics they found
that people were less likely to dislike
the button yeah
i could have told i could have told you
that youtube if you remove the function
of something people are not going to use
it as much i could have told you i could
have told you this there was no need for
small experiment i don't get like what i
feel like that has to be more in for
here there's no way that's it right it
makes no sense like it's still there no
one's just gonna use it so i thought
okay let's play a devil's advocate here
and try and
argue for why the dislike button is a
good thing or removing it sorry and i
acknowledge that youtube is a big side
and the way i interact with youtube it's
a small percentage of what represents
the entire site right i don't share the
same experience with everyone and i
understand that youtube probably know
through their small experiments better
i'm willing to admit that yes i am and
it always kind of bothered me on videos
when there's like five dislikes on
someone doing this charity event and
they raised a ton of money and this is
an inarguably positive thing right and
there's still
a couple dislikes on that video and
you're like why who did that why would
you do that those people should not be
allowed to this like that that's bullsh
same thing with just wholesome videos in
general some videos are just so nice
that no one should be allowed to dislike
it all right i don't want to hear your i
don't care no one cares that you dislike
it everyone else loves it okay so in
that sense yeah yeah i do agree another
point is that other websites don't have
a dislike button either like twitter
instagram tick tock there's no dislikes
but the thing is
it's a bit different with youtube
because on instagram or
tick tock at least all you do is keep
scrolling and that's it you don't care
you don't need to have a dislike button
if you don't like something you just
move on right but with youtube it's an
indication of if it's a good video or
not if you want to commit to watching it
which leads me to a point and probably
the main point of why keeping the
dislike bar is good is because you know
if you're looking up a tutorial video
and it has twenty percent or more
dislike count i'm not gonna watch that
video i know it's a bad tutorial it's
not gonna waste my time and i'm not
gonna get annoyed by watching it youtube
is saying that we are making this
account private to protect our creators
by reducing targeted dislikes attacks on
their channel so that's one of the main
reasons that they're removing it but i
never seen that have you seen that what
are they referencing exactly targeted
harassment
usually when that happens
it's when someone's getting cancelled
right that function already exists if
you're getting targeted by a ton of
dislikes it's like oh remove the dislike
part what are you gonna do right so it's
like they're fixing a problem that
already didn't need to be fixed i think
if that's a reasoning at least what
they're saying i i don't really
understand that okay so why keeping the
dislike bar here's my case listen up
anytime there's a lot of dislike on a
video it's because it's not good that's
it
it's not a good video
and like i said before it's helpful to
know if a video is good or not if you
want to spend time watching it and
number three which is there's enough hot
takes online already i don't wanna let
these people keep having a voice okay
i'm sick of every dumbass giving their
opinion with no backlash okay
this is why everyone hates twitter if
twitter had a dislike bar no one would
hate it as much because then you
wouldn't have to see it with dumb ass
ideas all the time okay
that's a small thing i'm willing to
admit but even then on that note twitter
community invented a whole concept of
having to figure out what the dislikes
are by by the ratio of the tweet how
many people comment on it it's so stupid
so it's like clearly an inherent thing
that people want whether you have it or
not does that make sense i think so uh
it's also a great tool for creators this
is how it looks like for me when i
upload i can see a percentage of how
many people like and how many people
disliked
which is a great tool because sometimes
you know if a video gets a lot of views
that doesn't necessarily mean people
like it i use it all the time to know if
people want more of a certain type of
video even if it doesn't really perform
uh it's actually really motivating for
stuff that doesn't perform as well
because i know at least a smaller
portion of fans really like it like book
reviews and
i don't know philosophy videos whatever
something that isn't going to attract a
large amount of my audience
at least no right so it's a great tool
to use for that and youtube is to be
fair saying that creators will still be
able to find the exact this accounts in
youtube studio for each video if you'd
like to but also referencing then what
they said before is that it changes how
people use the button
so
[Music]
i'm willing to admit i don't know what
the outcome is going to be so there's no
point in really getting pissed off about
it i will get kind of annoyed to be
honest if it does turns out that i can't
use this percentage thing anymore
because i do find it very useful but it
remains to be seen but it's kind of like
well if it ain't broke why fix it right
i don't know but i'm willing to reserve
my judgment on that point thank you
unbiased news reporter thank you uh
youtube is also replying to some extra
points where they're saying you can
still dislike videos to further
personalize and tune your
recommendations no one now stop now oh
my god i forgot about this the biggest
point ever some videos deserve public
pushback right okay
same reason as i don't want to see you
know it sucks to see
wholesome videos get this thing you know
that girl that punched a dog or whatever
i want to dislike that video i really do
or uh when people make videos on on
other creators that just passed away or
celebrities i want to dislike that video
i really do don't take that away from me
and i want other people to know and i
want to i want to see the dislike bar
and i want to go yeah that's right we
hate you everyone hates you stop doing
this they also replied to this isn't
about protecting small creators someone
said this it's about protecting big
brand and advertisers
we see why some folks might think that
but it's absolutely not
and it's like yeah i didn't even think
of that you know when same thing when
you see those crappy political
commercials that gets a ton of views
because i don't know pushed by algorithm
i don't know i always get take a great
satisfaction in the fact that i see that
a lot of people are disliking it and i
think hey maybe i'm not the only crazy
one this is great maybe i'm not the only
one that hates this garbage political
so yeah youtube clearly already
knows everything that's already been
said so there's and they already decided
they're going to move on with it so
there's really no point in even
complaining about i don't even know why
i'm talking about this
but if it does help other creators maybe
they're too scared to say
that this is actually because this is an
unpopular opinion i guess yeah i get
that i just don't buy it i don't see it
but that's just me the real question
that remains to be answered is what's
gonna happen to the most legendary video
can this video get the same amount of
dislikes as likes what's gonna happen to
it i need to know this you've gone too
far youtube i can't believe it that's it
poppy samurai gloria bye